[Musique]
bocoum a demandé 12 ans et leur nouveau
smartphone elle aussi sereine aussi frau
deux nouveaux smartphones qui sont
vraiment dédié pour les créatifs pour
les créateurs alors qu'est ce que t'es
smartphone peut se faire mais c'est ce
qu'on va faire on se balade dans paris
on va regarder différents points y avoir
de la vidéo il va y avoir de la photo il
ya plein de vidéos différentes que ce
soit sur de l'ia de l'embellissement
différents fitch a même des trucs
l'ennuyait de la vidéo pourtant il ya
plein de trucs
[Musique]
le constat est le suivant il ya de plus
en plus de réseaux sociaux que ce soit à
tik tok et même des changements soient
des raisons qu'on connaît on va sur
instagram y aller' il sur youtube via
les chances à tous formats courts qui se
met en place avec de la création qui est
super intéressante et vous direct avec
votre smartphone saikua crève pouvait
partager d'être acquis génial échéance
cinq des smartphones comme le rainbow
six et les rênes aux six proviennent
vraiment répondre à cette question et à
cette problématique en vous proposant
différents filtres vous proposant
différentes solutions pour pouvoir venir
travailler que ce soit aussi bien en
photo sous il cherche pas moins un stade
g des jolies poteau par pascal puisque
vous voyez pouvait faire vous pouvez
également le fer avec les vidéos garde
tout cas ça intéressant c'est notamment
la vidéo mode portrait je vous montrais
on va se faire les tests ensemble il ya
pas mal de choses je pense que tous
qu'ils sont ça va pas rien mais dans
l'ensemble il ya tout qui sont cools et
voyez les géants gorillapod j'ai le réno
syspro dessus je peux me filmer et ça
c'est cool très cool alors maintenant le
seul petit bémol que j'ai ici c'est
comme c'est pas deux prises jack pour
brancher un micro extérieur et bien je
peux pas venir améliorer la qualité du
son je voudrais que la qualité du son du
micro comme ça je ferais pas mieux voilà
ça c'est un peu le point de regrets sans
venir bloguer pour le reste ça intéresse
rachetant plus le bras mais j'ai même un
mode qui une trace n'a égalisé je ne
regardais ce que j'ai fait juste at on
savait que ça bouge un petit peu
gorillapod l'aja mode ultra stabiliser
normalement ça devrait faire ça me force
et tendre le bras un mec le gorillapod
assez loin que ça bien croquer un peu
dans l'image avec la stabilisation
électronique mais bon ça fonctionne
quand même plutôt bien très salée a
fonctionné plutôt bien je regardais et
je trouve ça cool voyez or après c'est
toujours pareil lorsque vous éloignez
vous perdez un petit peu en qualité
audio viens vous parler comme ça c'est
un peu mieux mais bon pratiquent déjà
il existe trois façons principal de
venir filmer avec ce smartphone je suis
sur le rainbow six la première c'est
voulais filmer un peu classiquement sans
stabilisation sans rien donc à vous
filmer leur allemand si vous le prenez
la main forcément ça va bouger davantage
c'est pas forcément la meilleure
solution la meilleure solution pour
récupérer en qualité d'image c'est
d'activer lie à l'intelligence
artificielle qui va venir booster pas
mal de choses notamment les couleurs
fabre affirme ce savant mélange qui a
fonctionné beaucoup mieux et qu'ils ont
plus de venir ajouter de la
stabilisation électronique parce que
simon optiques sont moreno si ce n'est
absolument pas stabilisée mais je le
prends j'aime être un peu plus
stabilisée ça irait un petit peu mieux
mais si vous voulez pousser la stab à
fond il ya un troisième le troisième au
semo stabilisé si vous n'avez pas dit
gasquet vous allez perdre un petit peu
en termes de couleurs ça sera un peu
plus tôt sera moins bien par contre ça
va pas bouger du tout ça sera beaucoup
plus stabilisée
donc ça c'est cool c'est rassurant par
contre s'il faut vraiment tendre le bras
voyez si je veux vraiment être dans le
champ je m'éloigne de la source donc en
termes de qualité audio je viens perdre
voilà mais si je me baladais en mode
bloguer ça qu'il faudra appréciez vous
le posez sur un trépied vous le posez
avec de l'ia c'est ce qui irait mieux et
dans les trois cas et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez le focus
tracking c'est à dire connaître mon
visage ça fait le point sur moi donc ça
voilà ça c'est intéressant donc ça ça
que j'aurais no 6 sur le réseau si ce
procès à peu près la même chose sauf
qu'ici vous avez un capteur d'être
principale qui est juste là qui est lui
par contre est stabilisé optiquement ont
déjà ça va venir je vois un petit peu
donc si vous le prenez la main vous
allez avoir une sabbatique bon c'est pas
mal mais c'est pas complètement optimale
pour optimiser tout ça vous activez l'ia
ça va venir jouer sur les couleurs les
contrats ces détails là nestea les
compagnies et savent apporter aussi une
stabilisation électronique en plus donc
ça vous a des stades électronique vous
avez la stalle optique ce qui fait que
si vous le prenez la main comme ça ça
veut dire améliorer un petit peu tout ça
alors c'est pas non plus parfait parfait
parce que si vous voulez la meilleure
stabilisation il faut activer la
spéculation explique mais comme soit une
hausse ici si vous avez plus dia et
voyez une fois de plus belle comme on
vient beaucoup trompé dans l'image il
faut l'éloigné davantage pour avoir un
plan un peu plus large et une fois de
plus en terme de qualité audio on vient
de perdre également parce que il faut se
rapprocher pour avoir un meilleur signal
donc il doit venir filmer en conditions
de faible luminosité
aubenas dans un tunnel à paris mais
obligé peut vous mettre ailleurs au
sikkim rouler ces quelques photos il ya
un peu moins de lumière alors je pense
que ça donne mais moi je triche
j'utilise des petit trépied c'était
facile
[Musique]
jeter dessus alors je mets sur le pied
délibérément raynaud 6 raynaud six pros
il existe différents modes sur ses
smartphones en terme de vidéo qui sont
super intéressante justement pour les
créatifs et la toute première c'est le
portrait pro alors portrait provost le
voyez sa part me le faire en vidéo alors
là on y sera aussi se régaler sont six
j'ai l'impression regarder la route
juste au dessus de mon oreille hop il
voit il a un peu de mal là et si envers
sur l'autre ce pro et pro c'est un peu
pareil en fait donc il ya des choses où
ils vont bon gars il est beaucoup plus
là c'est pareil la ola voyais au niveau
des cheveux sur le pro là je regarde
tout de suite là c'est un peu dur et si
je regarde sur l'autre sur no6 ouais on
le voit qu'il est en train de calculer
qu'il est en train de perdre alors c'est
vrai comme ça bon ça fonctionne
peut-être que si je bouge non ça se voit
quand même ça se voit bon les faits
rigolo c'est vrai que c'est assez
marrant on peut faire des choses on peut
régler sont bloquées plus ou moins de
boké donc dans l'idée je trouve ça pas
mal mais c'est pas encore
suffisamment bon en terme de calcul pour
qu'il soit complètement invisible on se
fait exactement le même exercice avec
les caméras derrière alors là je ne vois
pas j'ai pas le moniteur mais j'ai
regardé juste après dites moi vous est
ce que ça vous paraît mieux pas mieux au
niveau des cheveux au niveau des
contours au niveau des oreilles est ce
que ça fonctionne bien on a également la
vidéo avec de l'intelligence
artificielle alors qu'est ce que ça
vient faire ici eh bien ça vient
améliorer la clarté améliorer les
lumières améliorer la luminosité
améliorer la teinte de peau le contraste
les détails les couleurs en passant
c'est faire un petit peu tout ça donc là
s'est activée et maintenant je vais
directives et là c'est complètement
désactivé on va râler dans quelques
instants si une différence auprès ciel
vous paraît tout de suite vous l'automne
si vous voyez différences peuvent le
marquer tout de suite emballé dans les
commentaires moi je fais des rochers une
fois de plus je vous ferai un petit
retour complet dans quelques heures la
chanterelle film et l'écran durant nos
six pros avec le réussissent peu
schizophrénique qui vous montrer un mode
qui existe qui peut être utilisé ces
notes d'embellissement pouvait venir
déjà commencé pas on va y aller on
bourrine lui c'est votre visage regardez
ma peau voilà n'a plus rien à voir le
visage plus fin
ça me retrait si la tête en fait le
visage plus fin les yeux agrandis
regardez mes yeux ça me fait hyper peur
le nez plus fins et du taf chez moi
n'importe quoi le menton plus grand plus
petit
ok c'est ouf un comme ça marche bien le
visage plus petit ou êtes prêts
ok retouché pas ce que c'est
et puis 3d on y va à fond donc voyez ça
me fait une espèce de tête avec 1 1 j'ai
l'impression d'avoir des très grands
yeux puis d'avoir 15 ans et quand je
reviens au naturel
on pourra la vache et puis vous l'avez
vu il ya un truc qui marche super bien
c'est le focus tracking regarder abriel
qui à l'automate est savoureux connais
ma tête et ça me suit quel que soit leur
âge noël ça reconnaît mon visage ça fait
le point sur mon visage ça fait la
netteté sans visage donc ça c'est pareil
c'est disponible tout ça c'est tout ce
que je vous ai montré sur les deux
smartphones ce soit le renne aussi
souveraine aussi ce propos tout en
sachant que ce focus tracking est
compatible avec la fonction
embellissement également avec la vidéo
il ya jusqu'à en 4k à 60 images par
seconde sur le modèle professionnel et
jusqu'en 1080p à 60 images par seconde
tsonga no 6 et son aide aussi à mende
exclu qu'il veut vraiment cool c'est le
mode portrait noir et blanc tout est
noir et blanc sauf moi moi je suis en
couleurs ça s'est une fois de plus c'est
intéressant pour les créatifs vous
faites comme vous voulez on avait aussi
mis en mode paysage peut mettre en mode
portrait comme vous voulez je pense à
des réseaux comme tik tok ce n'est pas
être vraiment marrant si on veut
vraiment mettre le sujet en perspective
le maître sujet en avant par rapport au
fond pourquoi pas après c'est pas
complètement parfait parfait tel qu'un
qui parle beaucoup avec les mains comme
moi ça marchera un peu moins bien mais
si vous vous concentrez que vous bougez
pas trop ça peut fonctionner ça dépend
tout un chacun de ce que vous voulez en
faire alors après on est toujours limité
par rapport à la capacité de calcul du
processeur mais vous êtes malgré tout on
arrive à faire des choses qui sont assez
rigolote et on a une deuxième
fonctionnalité qui est liée uniquement
aurait no 6 et bien c'est le ralenti
c'est qu'on appellera le super ralenti
vous venez naviguer dans vos menus là
vous arrivez ici vous avez ralenti juste
en haut alors là déjà voyez on est sur
la caméra d'avant que ça marcherait pas
pareil mais si vous switchez sur la
caméra derrière vous le voyez on est en
960 images par seconde mais landes en
720p
[Musique]
c'est super intéressant le
positionnement de l'opo par rapport à
ces produits pourquoi parce qu'ici on
nous parle de créateurs dont nous parle
de créatif de personnes qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs je sais pas
si c'est votre cas vous pouvez dès
maintenant me le dire en bon commentaire
est d'ailleurs un sujet si vous avez que
ce soit le tictoc une chaîne youtube ou
instagram je sais pas quoi marquer les
en bas en commentaire comme ça on ira
découvrir et ça c'est bien donc on voit
que des marques comme mots il vienne
draguer ce public elle viendra gay c'est
créatif pour leur dire regardez on al
houthi on a les outils qui sont faits
pour vous alors maintenant que le boulot
est plutôt bien fait dans l'ensemble la
vidéo marche bien autant qu'elle peut
marcher avec la puissance de calcul que
vous avez derrière on les soirs chez
qualcomm sur le pro soit chez mediatek
avec le 6 on voit qu'on va beaucoup plus
loin au niveau des smartphones pour la
création vidéo moi je continue à
travailler comme je le fais pour
l'instant en tout cas avec mon boîtier
mais quitte à aller en extérieur je
trouve ça intéressant de pouvoir prendre
un smartphone le mode portrait vidéo
s'est pas encore complètement ça mais ça
avance une vraie différence de cliquer
300 euros d'écart entre les deux
produits c'est quand même paraît il ya
un écran effectivement incurvé on est
pétri cas un peu plus grosse sur le
proxy autre ajout vraiment à pas
grand-chose de 100 millions peur ça
change vraiment pas bien l'histoire la
performance forcément derrière avec les
processeurs le fait qu'on est sur le 6
du 8 gigas de ram et du 128 gia du
stockage non extensible je le précise
alors après ce qui est intéressant c'est
que si le stockage n'est pas plein eh
bien vous avez une techno qui peut venir
prendre mon envol stockage pour vous
créer de la ram virtuel dont vous pouvez
voir 5 gigas de ram supplémentaire en
plus de vos huit et sur le modèle pro au
delà des 12 et 256 que vous avez vous
pouvez monter jusqu'en 12 non c'est du
combien 12 + 7 non extensible à là
dessus aussi c'est pas mal ça me d'aller
un peu plus loin en terme de performance
pourquoi pas ça peut me tenter côté pur
technophiles 1 on a de la pellinière 4x
dans les deux cas la différence que vous
avez section leur no6 vous allez lui à
fès 2 points 1 sur rennes aussi ce
propos le fs trois points en ayant un
peu plus vite en lecture et en écriture
ce qui est aussi intéressant avec ses
smartphones je vous en ai déjà parlé de
la super look de au pot est bien c'est
qu'on se pose plus la question réelle de
l'autonomie alors l'autonomie là dessus
c'est un jour et demi deux jours ça va
dépendre de vous de vos usages bien
évidemment mais on se pose plus vraiment
la question parce que grâce à la superbe
2.0 vous avez de la charge 65 watts sa
boule recharge bâche membres vip sont
très nocives ou de recharger en 28
minutes de 0 à 100% c'est énorme parce
que soit le modèle professionnel vous
êtes en 31 minutes qui fait que vous
posez plus la question de la charge vous
prenez vous le branchez vous rechargez
très vite le temps de vous préparer vous
repartez vous êtes parti pour un vide
donc ça c'est vraiment vraiment cool
donc la partie autonomie c'est pour ça
aussi vachement rassurant côté design
c'est des smartphones qui sont assez
intéressants relativement différent sauf
au niveau de l'apparence qu'on appelle
le haut pour glos qui donne cet effet un
peu pas été alors moi j'ai deux couleurs
en fait dans une liste de trois pour
être très clair sur le réseau six mois
j'ai la couleur bleue arctique il existe
également sur le règne aussi ce problème
et il existe également un noir stellaire
tournoi roues pour hulot c'est sympa et
vous avez le green r c'est celui que
j'ai ici moi sur le réno six pros mais
vous l'avez également le bleu arctique
comme je vais montrer ici la grosse
différence qu'on va retrouver avec
lauren aussi c'est qu'on dit sur un
écran plat ici il ya absolument pas
d'incurver l'accord mais vous avez sur
le modèle pro il y en a pour tout le
monde tous les goûts est ce que vous
avez de la cuvée ou pas du lac huron et
ça c'est vraiment une question de goûts
et de couleurs au niveau des écrans
c'est sensiblement la même chose vous
avez de la molette d'un côté l'autre
vous êtes sûr de 6 43 pouces sur le réno
6 est sûre du 6,55 blues bon [ __ ] pas
une grosse grosse différence dans les
deux cas on est sur un écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement de 90 ans
fréquence d'échantillonnage tactile 280
hertz et du full hd plus la grosse
différence au niveau du son 5 sur
raineau six années au parleur mono haut
parleurs stéréo sur le pro il tourne sur
collants os 11.3 basé sur l'android 11
alors vous connaissez probablement
coloro s vous êtes déjà fait une vidéo
complètement explicative on a fait un
tour à halle et la regarder la visionner
si vous ne l'avez pas fait ça peut
vraiment finir vous aider ou faire
basculer un dans le choix de de passer
chez au port ou pas sur leur haine aussi
sont à l'arrière trois capteurs on a
deux qui sont réellement intéressant
c'est grand-angle et luttera grand-angle
le grand temps que 164 mégapixels
l'ultra grand angle c'est un 8
mégapixels est ok why not the la macro
en 2 mégapixels bon voila si c'est pas
si vous aimez peindre la macro ne suis
pas un traître être innovant fans mais
on peut tandis qu'à l'avant vous avez
une caméra de saïfi qui est planqué
juste là c'est une 30 2 mégapixels et
c'est exactement la même chose vous y
retrouvez ici au niveau de votre modèle
pro caméra de celle fille de 30 2
mégapixels mais par contre vous avez
quand même vachement plus haut niveau du
prg ou enfin vachement un peu plus vous
avez votre capteur principal de 50 méga
pixels ça c'est cool un ultra grand
angle de 16 mégapixels toujours la macro
qui va être planck est là et puis vous
avez un téléobjectif de 13 mégapixels et
après vous êtes capteurs de température
de couleur d'un côté l'autre avoue la
verde il est situé là il est situé là ce
qui l'est c'est qu'ici votre capteur
principal 50 méga pixels c'est là
souligné mieke 766 qui était développé
en partenariat avec sony sony et hop hop
qui équipe le finepix trois pros que je
vais présenter en début d'année qui est
le smartphone le plus haut de gamme de
au pot un capteur qui est complètement
stabilisé dont vous aviez réalisation
optique et électronique donc pour le
louper absolument aucune photo que ça
bouge pas c'est vraiment bien donc c'est
vraiment des gros points forts de celui
là même si effectivement ça draine aussi
son vous dit vous avez un capteur de 64
mégapixels vous laissez pas avoir par
les chiffres le 50 méga pixels est bien
meilleur que le 64 que vous avez sur le
règne aussi donc si vous voulez des
meilleures photos et bien scellé raynaud
syspro vous avez un superbe capteurs son
grand angle et vous avez en plus un
téléobjectif permet de venir chercher un
peu plus dans l'image il ya un peu plus
mais pas trop jusqu'en x 5 au delà c'est
rapidement pas terrible faisons autour
du goûter des photos on commence par le
reno 6 place de la concorde toujours
très très joli ça fonctionne en tout cas
je vous ça plutôt bien il ya un côté un
petit peu pâle et pas extrêmement
sursaturé mais j'aime bien le boulot est
fait c'est assez efficace
l'ultra grand en grèce très cohérent et
après on peut venir zoom et un peu dans
l'image comme la pâte et l'objectif
c'est le même que le capteur principal
mais ça fait le boulot alors n'allez pas
trop loin bouyer parce que vous perdez
un peu en qualité vous parlez beaucoup
en qualité la caméra de celle fille est
un peu pâlotte on a un petit peu de mal
au niveau de la gestion des auc lumière
mais on pourra se faire quelques petits
souvenirs c'est pas ici qu'on va voir
briller les couleurs les plus pêchus les
plus saturés on continue ensuite avec un
autre capteur principal
on n'a pas les normes plage dynamique on
n'a pas beaucoup de contrastes on n'a
pas de très grosse couleurs mais malgré
tout ça fait le boulot et c'est
relativement honnête quelle que soit la
typologie plutôt vous vouliez faire donc
pour quelques petits souvenirs eh bien
je trouve que le renault 6 reste malgré
tout assez cohérent et en conditions de
faible luminosité date ça fait le taff
plutôt pas mal alors là je les poser sur
un pied si vous le tenez à la main ça
sera un petit peu différent on peut
faire également de la macro
personnellement la macro je suis pas
très très très fade on peut pour autant
faut-il le faire je suis pas sûr on est
maintenant sur le réno syspro là c'est
le grand angle là et là c'est le grand
temps là je me suis juste rapprocher et
là on passe sur l'île très grand-angle
vous allez voir que 13 vente on est
quand même beaucoup plus pêchus beaucoup
plus saturé vous avez un poil plus de
contraste assez rigolo mais ça
fonctionne quand même plutôt pas mal
dans l'ensemble on peut venir jouer ici
grâce au téléobjectif attention à pas
trop vous rapprocher son camp vous allez
perdre rapidement en qualité mais en
termes de gestion de plage dynamique
sauf que le boulot est relativement bien
fait en captant principal l'ultra grand
tante beaucoup plus saturé on vient se
rapprocher avec le téléobjectif en bref
c'est un smartphone que je trouve très
polyvalent au niveau de la photo
elle-même sur les conditions de photos
de nuit posé sur un pied ça marche bien
l'ultra grand temps que nous ramène
aussi beaucoup de couleurs dans ces
conditions là je sois vraiment sympa on
se rapproche bon après pas trop ce en
quoi ça devient rapidement le bazar
pareil de la macro bon voilà pour moi la
macro c'est à oublier totalement après
grand classique vous avez du nfc vous
avez du wifi 6 on a des différences de
certification sur le rainbow six et de
l'ip et 54 tandis que le côté celle ipx4
ya pas de vip et 68 assez surprenant et
une double vanos il est un indice de
réparabilité et pas c'est dur à dire ça
y est l'année de réparabilité de 8
points 5 sur 10 en terme de vidéo je
vais préférer les rénos si ce que fait
reprochés auraient eu nos six pros c'est
des fois d'être un petit peu inconstant
lorsque vous venez filmé sans ia sans
rien flatte pas moment on arrive d'avoir
un rendu qui va être sursaturé alors
peut-être qu'une mise à jour va venir le
corriger mais pour l'instant c'est vrai
que le réno six pros avec ce côté
sursaturé c'est pas ouf avec la fonction
il n'y a pas un moment ça réagit aussi
un petit peu bizarrement en termes de
colorimétrie ça vous fait une espèce de
contenu un peu vert c'est assez
surprenant peut-être une fois de plus
qu'une mise à jour va venir corriger ça
par contre que j'aime bien avec lorenzo
6 même si c'est pas le meilleur vidéo
fun du marché soyons clairs je le trouve
très constant dans sa façon de traiter
l'image en vidéo alors que je trouve
qu'avec le réno syspro il ya une vraie
disparités entre la vidéo sans rien la
vidéo avec qui a hélas super
stabilisation l'image est pas tout à
fait la même ça c'est pour la vidéo par
contre pour la photo raynaud syspro très
clairement il sera bien meilleur il ira
plus loin il y aura un meilleur
traitement c'est aussi un smartphone qui
va être beaucoup plus polyvalent avec
l'ultra grand tante qui as est saturé
qui est pêché mais qui est sympa avec ce
grand temps que ce capteur co développe
et sony qui marche bien et peut être
l'été l'objectif pour venir chercher un
peu plus loin donc si vous êtes créatif
ve vous êtes plus créatifs photo raynaud
six pros si vous êtes plus créatifs
vidéo raynaud six combats par le coup de
coeur il est ici soprano 6 sauf que
c'est un excellent rapport qualité prix
et si vous êtes un gamer ces deux
smartphones iront bien ils ont ce qu'il
faut sous le capot sans aucun problème
on en plus en retours haptiques qui est
assez sympa qui va venir apporter en
immersion lorsque vous venez jouer à
deux jeux au delà de toute l'expérience
logiciel qui est très sympa le renne
aussi s'il est dispo au tarif de 499
euros je trouve bien positionné je suis
là je trouve beaucoup plus chers coûtent
trop cher je sais pas
799 euros alors vous avez +1 forcément
vous en douterez mais on est quand même
à 300 euros de plus il ya des offres de
lancement sont intéressantes c'est comme
ça jusqu'à la fin du mois de septembre
j'ai publié cette vidéo nomade septembre
2021 donc jusqu'à la fin du mois de
septembre et bien pour ce match a duré
nos si vous avez 149 euros de cadeaux
avec des encore free et une coque
lumineuse qui vous sont offertes donc
assez cool tandis que sur le rainbow six
projets j'ai appris par coeur c'est une
heure de 239 euros de cadeaux avec un an
qu'au ixe au pot bande et une coque en
silicone a vous de me dire ce que vous
en pensez vous en bas en commentaire on
voulait trouver le smartphone et lequel
pourrait vous intéresser bien évidemment
si vous intéresse le lien est en bas
dans la description des bisous de
l'amour pour n'être de vos militants